I'm thrilled we feel incredible very
surreal kind of out-of-body experience I
am ecstatic about the news today it's
surprising I'm still I think a little
bit of shock it's a momentous remarkable
day for a lot of us here especially in
California not only because we saw DOMA
struck down in to get a broad decision
but also the more narrow decision on
Prop 8 thrills a lot of us it was legal
in California to get married and we had
that right taken away by an ephemere
called prop 8 we fought at the courts
and we were victorious today simply
blood I mean there's a lot of steps
along the way it opens doors for so many
people to a happier life as the sign
here says today we are more American
than we were this morning when we
started out to see today marks an
historic day an historic day for civil
rights an historic day for the
Constitution of the United States of
America today is an affirmation that
America works and in our Constitution
upholds the rights for all citizens it's
more about not just about having a
wedding but it's more about having the
right
those rights mean a lot hopefully we
won't have to continue to tell our
grandchildren embarrassing stories on
our history as the Prima card is spoken
in favor of love and favor of dignity in
favor of humanity we're just here where
does ourselves that's all that really
matters for yourself love is love I mean
love it's up I couldn't wonderful fit I
love her and when I heard you know when
we both heard it was just
we both texted each other we were on our
way there now every little girl has
surgery
whatever we just have a different dream
like marrying another girl and now that
it's
like we just have
he'll say yes in my ass is that that
what you wanna hear he'll say yes I am
at my age now it just makes it official
that i'm a spinster it's definitely
something that people are gonna be
asking us i'm sure i haven't met anybody
yet but never know you know maybe one of
these days i have i been somebody I'd be
over to it it's nice no I have options
we kept at it we worked hard and we did
it and hopefully we won't ever have to
do it again I just want to make sure
that we we guys keep it classy we're
gonna do this let's do it right oh
speaking of keeping a glass